okay so we are going to be a tad bit
dangerous we're not really dangerous
we're going to experiment a little bit
and the reason why is because of the
fact that kind of patrolling around and
poking around and looking on YouTube I
have never seen anybody make a
chronological series of x-men videos and
the reason why is because it's just so
hard to do it's kind of funny because I
had been tagged in a tweet from
egoraptor over a game grumps who wanted
to know what to read after reading a
house of M with the x-men and that's
what really confuses people people read
Marvel comics and they're just kind of
like okay like house of M was designed
to consolidate the mutants but then
where do you go from there and it's kind
of a funny scenario because to talk
about this for a second before we get
into this this origin of Darwin the way
that Marvel did things kind of was was
really more like a gradual change right
like casada took over in 2000 and said
okay let's reshape let's rework the
landscape all that kind of good stuff
here so he said we have thousands of
mutants we need to reduce the number
down so that we can focus on stories
that emphasize the core mutant base and
write more character-driven stuff and so
house of M was designed for the purpose
of reducing the mutant population from
thousands if not millions all the way
down to like 198 and then from there
Marvel took the step of going through
and saying okay let's start focusing on
character driven things and so between
the story house of M and the story
Second Coming it was all just basically
story arcs it was things like Messiah
Complex Messiah wore x-men deadly
Genesis manifest destiny endangered
species different things like that I'm
stating all those stories out of order
they didn't actually go in that
chronological order but the fact remains
it was all just story German stuff after
second coming then Marvel said okay now
you can pretty much read whatever you
want to Ephram they're really just kind
of breaks down into like uncanny x-men
and really all-new x-men is really all
there is to it but there were all kinds
of stories in a minute took place and so
an idea that I've been kicking around
and I'm kind of curious to see how
people would respond to it is basically
doing the same thing we did with in with
The Incredible Hulk
and just doing like a chronological
series of videos on the x-men and just
covering everything that happened with
the x-men roster whether it's you know
cable x-force x-factor all that kind of
stuff covering everything that happened
with the entire x-men universe between
house of M all the way up to all-new
all-different marvel I'm kind of toying
with that idea and I think it'd be kind
of cool to do but with regards to the
character of Darwin this comes out of
x-men deadly Genesis now x-men deadly
Genesis was the first major storyline to
be published by
Orvil after the events of house event
and what this story does or at least
what what the actual deadly Genesis
story does is that basically sees the
return of Charles Xavier at the events
of house of M and decimation as well as
the introduction of Vulcan the third
summers brother essentially just this
crazy powerful you know like beyond
omega-level mutant they can basically
just manipulate any form of energy it's
absolutely bonkers the kind of stuff
that he can do but the fact remains here
that with Darwin this guy's name is
Armando Munna Munoz I think is how you
pronounce it what does call him Armando
but the fact remains that he really kind
of has like a tragic story and that's
really one of the things that comes
across a lot of the a lot of the mutants
that we end up seeing in Marvel is a lot
of them come from tragic backgrounds in
some form or fashion
it makes for very compelling stories
sometimes we can identify with those or
at the very least we can identify with
the struggle they endure in trying to
just make it day by day but it's still a
pretty cool set of events and the reason
why is because of the fact that he is
struggling with a mom that hates him
because her husband left them now this
is par for the course with mutants right
like that's nine times out of ten that's
the case like parents give birth to a
mutant and they're do you know it is
kind of freaked out the difference here
is that some mutants are born with
physical appearances physical displays
of their mutation while others are not
and it's really kind of this crazy
scenario because it's almost like you
can look at Marvel Comics you can read
x-men stories and you could see where
groups like the Morlocks
for example mutants who have a physical
mutation you know whether it's because
they look different or because they're
made of paper or whatever the case may
be their mutation is one that people can
physically see and they shy away from
the public eye but they look at people
like Jean Grey you would never know that
Jean Grey is a mutant but she's one of
the most powerful telepaths and
telekinetics in all of Marvel Comics the
same thing with Emma Frost so unless he
turns to Diamond you would never know
that she's a mutant Charles Xavier the
whole nine yards telepaths usually have
an easier energy projectors like like
Cyclops he walks around with ruby quartz
glasses and he does looks like a guy
who's wearing a weird set of sunglasses
and that's it nobody ever really has a
reason to bat an eye because of that
their mutations are not obvious they
actually have to show you what it is
they can do with Darwin his mutation
wasn't as obvious but something was a
little off his arms were a little bit
longer his eyes were a little bit larger
than other children of his same age and
so because of that but whether is
because his father knew what was going
on or because his father had basically
hypothesized or assumed what was going
on the result
was that he effectively abandoned their
family he basically just kind of walked
out and the result is that he was left
with a verbally abusive mother now
following this Darwin's intelligence he
basically does kind of manifest it to
the point that he was insanely smart one
of the smartest kids in the country now
in truth writer Ed Brubaker is kind of
toying with this and we'll talk about
why here in a second but he's touring
with the possibility of why it is that
Darwin is as smart as he is but
regardless of the reason the fact
remains that his intelligence eventually
leads him to gaining the attention of
various schools all of which are vying
for the opportunity to have him enrolled
and become a part of what it is they
have going on and so the result is that
he's inducted and Biltmore Academy now
the problem with this is that in
Biltmore Academy the Advanced Education
Center he is basically isolated from his
family his mom really doesn't want to
have anything to do with him and the
idea of him being that smart means that
she could basically just kind of pass
him off on somebody else and say now
he's your responsibility
and she can just go and do whatever she
wants to do be alone whatever the case
may be but the other half of this is
that Ed Brubaker is really good when it
comes to fleshing out characters he's
really good when it comes to talking
about characters explaining what
characters are about what their
motivations are why they see the world
the way they do when it comes to the
x-men as far as a comic book goes this
is especially prominent with Wolverine
and the x-men more so than any other
title because it deals so exclusively
with what goes on in the Jean Grey
school for higher learning the x-men
comics are half personal life and half
superhero life and that was a trend that
was established by a Chris Claremont
right like that's why the Chris
Claremont run of x-men is just so huge
and so lauded and people say all is one
of the greatest runs of all time because
he emphasized the individual characters
in their own personal lives and so you
would open up an x-men comic by Chris
Claremont and you would be just as
likely to see storm teaching Kitty Pryde
about like you know about dresses and
how to walk like a woman and sit like a
woman and conduct herself like a woman
as you would the two of them fighting
against Magneto and so because of that
whole interpersonal relationship because
of that whole focusing on the characters
it became a core part of the x-men
series going forward you would end up
seeing stories like young x-men
different things like that even with you
know Avengers Academy and so on you
would see students dealing with their
own individual lives as well as what it
was like being inside of a school and as
we know inside schools it sucks like
school
like prisons right you got to go in
there you got to beat up the biggest
guide and make sure that everybody knows
they can't mess with you not to mention
that once you walk in the school you
can't leave for eight hours out of the
day you are in Florence Colorado's
maximum security prison so because of
that it is a it's a crazy situation but
the fact remains here that because of
his intelligence because of his physical
appearance
Darwin is basically just a target of
abuse and ridicule that's really all it
is
the kids at school will give him a hard
time one because of his intelligence and
it really kind of makes them feel dumb
but the other half is just because he
looks different and so because he's
constantly being taunted his mutant
powers manifest for the very first time
when one of the kids tries to drown him
in a toilet now of course with Darwin
his power basically allows him to
breathe underwater and the result is
that he begins lashing out and his
physical body begins to change to the
situation that he's in in the sense that
his hands turn into rock and he just
starts beating the absolute hell out of
these guys now following this he ends up
returning home for a little bit of time
off and when he does he ends up coming
home to I guess at some point during the
night uh his mom had was smoking a
cigarette it fell under the couch and
lit the house on fire and Darwin rescued
her without sustaining any damage to
himself whatsoever and so what ends up
happening is we end up finding out that
with Darwin himself his mutant power is
that his body is in a constant state of
flux now this is the difference between
mutant powers and Marvel Comics when it
comes to mutant powers and even just
powers in general you have what are
called active powers and you have
passive powers so with someone like
Wolverine he's got a passive ability his
body will heal from damage no matter
what happens he can't control his body's
healing factor you know he could be
walking down the street somebody will
shoot him in the back and he'll just
keep on walking and it'll heal
automatically you know he can't control
that on the other hand someone like
magneto has the ability to manipulate
the electromagnetic spectrum but it's
not passive it's active his body just
doesn't automatically control magnetism
otherwise everywhere he went he would
just basically be like a giant magnet
instead he has to actively control it on
his own with Darwin the way his powers
function they function according to any
given situation that he's in as well as
his own emotions and so because of this
when these various scientists begin
conducting experiments on him they put
him in a room that's completely blocked
his eyes developed to the point where he
can see in the dark when they put him in
a room and fill it with poisonous gas
his lungs filter the gas as if it were
air his
body always adapts to whatever situation
he's in and that is why he's basically a
beyond omega-level mutant because it
would seem that there's no clear defined
way to kill Darwin there's no way to
actually in his life if you shoot him
his body will heal if you set him on
fire his body will counter his body will
always adapt to whatever situation that
is sent and so ultimately following this
research that's done on Darwin a paper
is published now the important thing to
keep in mind here is this origin of
Darwin goes all the way back to like the
1950s or 1960s so this is in the very
early days almost immediately after the
original x-men team was formed and so
because of this mutants are really still
a pretty new phenomena in the realm of
Marvel Comics in the realm of the
superhero community they're pretty new
introduction I mean not a lot of people
know about that mutants have been around
for you know thousands and thousands of
years but they're just now coming into
the public eye and so Darwin is a very
intriguing character he's a very
intriguing thing to them because at this
point in time in the history of Marvel
Comics scientists are just now learning
about mutants and so when they're
learning that mutants with telepathy and
telekinesis and so on exists they subtly
stumble across this guy whose body can
adapt to virtually anything and so the
following the publishing of this paper
Darwin's mom basically makes it adamant
that she hates him because of the fact
that he's a mutant and this is to be
expected it's a core part of mutant
comics I mean it's a core part of the
x-men comics it's been this way really
since Chris Claremont wrote the story so
unless it's been like this great big
huge 40 year attempt by Marvel to invoke
social justice warrior and it's just the
nature of the story the other half of
this is that Darwin actually tries to
end his own life and the reason why is
because he's got no Drive he's got no
ambition no reason to stay going any
more you know his dad's out of the
picture his mom hates him kids at school
ridicule him he's apparently a mutant
doesn't like who he is he sees no future
for himself the problem is that the one
who steps off the building to try to
kill himself his body becomes so
incredibly light he floats to the ground
like a feather yet another instance
where Darwin simply cannot be killed and
so because of this you know in these
these last few moments he's actually met
with a guy who arrives and says look I
know a woman who's basically going
around and trying to find mutants that
have abilities you're trying to find
people with extraordinary skills she
wants to teach you how to use your power
she wants to introduce you to a man they
can help you understand your place in
the bigger picture all you have to do is
just be willing to accept and so what
this does is it basically leads
to the introduction of Darwin as part of
the original are really the second
iteration of the x-men team but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and ring this video to an end if
you guys are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video and you guys
want to see more videos like it let me
know down in the comments section
because I'm kind of curious I mean I'd
love to cover all the x-men stuff the
question is does anybody care enough to
watch it that's the real question
anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
ring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]